like this altitude I can run flat out
for a half-mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also do personal
question now it is
I must - any organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by thrive market thrive
market saves me a ton of money and it's
perfect for these crazy times thrive
market is a membership-based site on a
mission to make healthy living easy and
affordable for everyone you can
regularly save 25 to 50% off of normal
retail prices with member-only prices
for anything you can imagine
really whether it's keto paleo
gluten-free vegan whatever you can sort
by that you can find all types of food
you can find supplements you can find
non-toxic home products clean wine dog
food just about anything and let me give
you a personal example of just how much
you can save so my last order I ordered
primal Kitchen mayonnaise which is made
with avocado oil it's delicious Justin's
almond butter and the first was 25
percent off the Justin's almond butter
was 30 percent off raus homemade
marinara sauce which is awesome 26
percent off all said and done at the end
of my shopping I saved $39 on my order
so members and I'm a member can earn
wholesale prices every day and save an
average of 30 dollars on each order I'll
come back to that and through thrive
gives their one-on-one membership
matching program every paid thrive
market membership is matched with a free
one for a low-income family in need and
you can try thrive market a few
different ways they have the monthly
membership which is 995 per month they
have the 12-month membership for five
dollars a month which is billed at 59.95
and right now this is exclusive to you
guys you can get up to a $20.00 shopping
credit when you join today now remember
that I save 39 dollars on my order so
basically with one or two orders I pay
for the annual membership which is
pretty sweet so go to thrive market
dot-com forward slash Tim to give thrive
market a try you can like I said choose
between the membership models you'd like
to test out if it doesn't work for you
you can cancel for any reason within 30
days for a full refund
on top of that you will make back your
membership in savings as I have or they
give you credits to make up for the
difference so it's really win-win-win
all around and I would suggest check it
out go to thrive market comm forward
slash Tim you can receive up to $20.00
in shopping credit that's thrive market
comm forward slash Tim for up to $20.00
in shopping credit plus all of the other
great stuff that I mentioned one more
time check it out thrive market comm
forward slash Tim this episode of the
Tim Ferriss shows brought to you by
athletic greens I get us all the time if
I could only take one supplement what
would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time and extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens com forward
slash Tim again that's athletic greens
dot-com forward slash Tim for your free
travel pack with any purchase
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show this was a really
really fun one to record each and every
episode including this one it is my job
to interview world-class performers from
all different fields to tease out how
they do what they do what are their
habits belief systems favorite books etc
hopefully so you can apply and test
things in your own life my guest today
is Elizabeth Gilbert Elizabeth Gilbert
is the number one New York Times
bestselling author of big magic and Eat
Pray Love as well as several other
internationally best-selling books
although her nonfiction work catapulted
her to global fame Gilbert has been
critically acclaimed throughout her
career for her fiction and has been a
finalist for the National Book Award the
pen Hemingway award and the National
Book Critics Circle Award for those of
you don't know fiction those are very
very big deals Elizabeth has had an
extraordinary journey first as an
award-winning magazine journalist she
began her career writing for Harper's
Bazaar spin the New York Times Magazine
and GQ she was a three-time finalist for
the National Magazine Award and an
article she wrote in GQ about her
experiences bartending became the basis
for the movie coyote ugly Eat Pray Love
launched Gilbert into another
stratosphere altogether making her one
of the most iconic and beloved writers
of our time now with more than 15
million copies sold worldwide that is a
huge number
Eat Pray Love has been translated into
more than 30 languages and made into a
feature film in Time magazine named
Gilbert one of the 100 most influential
people in the world her TED talk about
creativity has nearly 10 million views
making it one of the most beautiful time
and this past fall Gilbert went on tour
with Oprah
speaking to 100,000 plus people along
the way
Gilbert also wrote the instant number
one New York Times bestseller big magic
subtitle creative living beyond fear
which dives deep into her own generative
process to explain where inspiration
comes from how ideas form and grow and
how to overcome the fears and suffering
that inevitably arise when we push at
boundaries and take a leap into the
unknown
her new book city of girls is a novel
set in the New York City theatre world
of
the 1940s and it hits all sorts of
fantastic fun tantalizing stuff that we
get into in this interview which covers
a lot of ground and what a pleasure it
was so without further ado please enjoy
this wide-ranging conversation with Liz
Gilbert you can find her Elizabeth
Gilbert calm and also on the socials at
Gilbert Liz on Twitter and Facebook and
at Elizabeth underscore Gilbert
underscore writer on Instagram Liz
welcome to the show hey Tim thanks for
having me I am thrilled to have you and
I have I have messages to impart my
girlfriend insisted that I tell you that
she loves you so that's that's important
to check I'll tell her I love you too I
have so many questions and we are we are
gonna improvise as we go and I thought I
would begin with the alpha wolf if you
don't mind
and this this was introduced to me and
for those who don't know this is a moth
talk slash presentation story slash
tearjerker slash laugh out loud
at moments tale that my girlfriend asked
me to listen to with her together in bed
before we went to sleep several months
ago and I saw that Ray's birthday her
60th birthday was just a few days ago
and I have questions about preparing for
this for the alpha wolf but perhaps you
could give people some context I fallen
in love with the moth partially thanks
to Neil Gaiman partially thanks to
Katherine burns and this was very strong
talk on a whole lot of levels but could
you speak to who Raya was a little bit
of context and then how to how you
prepared
that hmm there's quite literally nothing
I would rather talk about than race
so you started in a good place for me um
so Raya Elias was quite simply the love
of my life
she and I were friends for 17 years I
was married for most of that and just
very slowly and very quietly over the
years fell in love with her she was a
lesbian
Syrian Detroit raised rock-and-roll
hairdresser filmmaker author musician
who had always wanted to live just right
on the edge of life she had been a
speedball heroin junkie on the Lower
East Side of New York City in the 1980s
was in Rikers Island was in Bellevue was
in various rehabs and militate in
rehabilitation as homeless was oh god
she'd had such a storied life and then
she finally put it all down and she
spent 19 years clean and sober and when
I met her she was on the other side of
that recovery and she was the strongest
most extraordinary person I ever met and
as I said in that speech that I gave in
that talk that I gave at the moth about
her which I shared a year after she died
she was the most powerful person in
every room that she ever walked into and
I adored her
she was my guide she was my teacher she
was the rock the ground underneath my
feet she was the one person in the world
who always made me feel safe and she
didn't just make me feel safe I felt the
feeling that everyone had when Raya
walked into the room was oh thank god
ray is here everybody's safe that's what
the Alpha is right the Alpha is the
person who keeps the entire pack safe
and and because she was the most
powerful person in the in the room what
I always knew when she walked in was not
only would she make sure I was okay if
anybody was preying on me in any way she
would make sure the predator was okay
dude
like she had everybody under her wing to
make sure that people were all right you
know I'm she just had this way of
handling humans like nothing I've ever
seen in my entire life
and I absolutely adored her and I was a
loyal wife and I loved my husband and
the three of us were really good friends
and there was no way in the world that I
was ever gonna cross that line I just
kept that love very quietly in my heart
and we all just had a beautiful life
together until the day that she was
diagnosed with terminal pancreatic and
liver cancer and I got a phone call from
her saying that she'd gotten this
diagnosis and that they said she had six
months to live and from that point
forward it was no longer possible for me
to keep that love hidden and very
swiftly after that I had a conversation
with my husband and said I need to go
and be with Rhea and to not and no one
was surprised by this he wasn't
surprised by it he'd seen it for years
and he very in one of the greatest acts
of courage and dignity I've ever seen
anybody do he very graciously stepped
out of the way and and we separated and
I went to be with her and I was with her
until the end of her life so that's who
Raya was and that's who she was to me as
for that speech that I gave at the moth
that talked what I had what I was
challenged to do in 12 minutes
was to try to get over the net who that
person was the most epic human being I'd
ever met and I decided the way to do
that was to tell a few stories about the
experience of her death and dying which
were mostly based on ideas that I had
about how she was going to become very
helpless and I was going to have to be
her hero and protect her versus the
reality of the situation which is that
she never became helpless she remained
the Alpha in the entire situation she
was a really hard patient to take care
of for that reason she absolutely
refused to cooperate with my version of
some airy-fairy soft hippie depth that I
wanted to give to her and instead she
died the way she lived like a like the
badass
fierce unrelenting warrior that she was
and it was brutal and it was beautiful
and and she never stopped taking us by
surprise right even up till the last
second was it difficult for you to have
the conversation with your husband or
difficult to prepare for this talk or
did both come to you very natural early
or something in between it was very
natural and very difficult and you know
I was I was only guided by again going
back to the teachings that Raya gave to
me one of her great expressions that she
lived by was the truth has legs and what
she meant by that and she would she
would expand on it and say it this way
the truth has legs it's the only thing
that will be left standing in the end so
at the end of the day when all the drama
has blown up and all the drama has
expressed itself and everyone has acted
up and acted out and and there's been
you know whatever else is happening when
all of that settles there's only going
to be one thing left standing in the
room always and that's going to be the
truth and Rhea's policy of life was
since that's where we're gonna end up
why don't we just start with it why
don't we just start with it and I can't
tell you how many times I heard her say
that and how many times I heard her just
go right to the center of it with people
where she'd be like okay
put your truth on the table let me put
my truth on the table let's skip the
drama and let's just go to the truth
because that's the only thing that's
ever gonna survive and let's let's just
begin you know right there and and that
was a truth the truth of my love for RIA
was I had reached a point where it could
just no longer be hidden I couldn't hide
it from myself anymore and I certainly
didn't want to hide it from this
wonderful man who I loved and still love
and you know there's that adage I think
David Foster Wallace said it the truth
will set you free but
not before it's had its way with you you
know it's it's a frightening thing but
but I felt I just felt like the only way
that I could honor how much I loved him
it was to honor that great man by
telling him the truth and and he honored
me in return by accepting it what did
you learn about grief your own grieving
process grief recovery plans anything
related to grief through that experience
so everything about Raya humbled me I
was one of her great roles in my life
was to just show me how you can plan
till God leaves Chicago you can play you
can plan till things get better you
can plan till the end of days and trust
me I'm a planner you know I am an
organized person I have you know I'm my
mom's lesson always in my childhood was
like the the best thing you could be
with somebody who had her ducks in a row
right like you know just get it all in
order get it all organized and life life
has a marvelous way of refusing to
cooperate with that and and so I did not
I planned to be a good loyal wife
and then God or the universe was like oh
that's a great plan you know good but
with the way that I say it now is good
guess
good guess Liz good guess like a really
good guess honorable guests well done
with the best of intentions but actually
that's not who that's not your love this
is your love and I spent years just
being like no it's not no it's not
because I have this plan and life's like
uh yeah it actually is it actually is
and and the point is going to come where
that truth is going to become bigger
than your plans and and that extended
into the way that I tried to manage I'm
using air quotes now managed ray as
death I also went into her death with a
plan we're gonna have it enlightened
death we're gonna have a real hospice
death we're gonna bring grief
bereavement experts in here to talk I
mean I laugh now because it's like you
know it's just
rheya like he's such a biker chick it's
like you're gonna bring a grief
bereavement expert in here like to talk
to me you know like give me a break I
don't know I'm gonna go down watching
football eating chicken wings and
smoking you know like this is like of no
interest in that and so she just waylaid
that plan completely and died on her own
terms and then I think by that point I'd
given up even having the idea of a plan
for grief I just remember I think I
walked into my grief kind of like just
naked and broken and just like okay what
do what do you have for me and and and
it just what it had for me was so
beautiful and so hard
I found that I guess I did have a plan
to a certain extent because I I still
thought that I was going to be good at
it like I love when I walk into really
hard things like I'm gonna be good at
this you can't be good at grief you
can't be good at it it's it's not
something that is to be mastered it's
something that's to be survived and it's
and it's something that has great
lessons for you but you certainly have
to drop any sense that you've got
control over it or that you can manage
it it's bigger than you and it's bigger
than us it's a it's a force of nature so
whether system and what I learned in
grief was you let it take you you just
have to let it take you when those waves
come you have to let them break over you
if you try to resist it will only hurt
you more and one of the things that
really shocked me and my grief was how
much rage there wasn't it you know I
don't think of myself as a very rageful
and angry person but my grief was shot
through with an absolute white-hot
boiling rage and I was I was enraged at
a TRAI I was enraged at rheya for not
dying the way I wanted her to I was
enraged at her for dying at all I was
enraged at her for leaving a whole bunch
of for me to take care of after she
died which also felt like how our life
together had been it's like why do I
have to handle everything why didn't you
arrange this why didn't you work this
out
like cuz I'm not that person you're that
person I've lived in the moment you make
plans so you figure it out you know I
was engaged at family members and
friends who I felt hadn't shown up for
her or for me in the way that I needed
them to and it was an incredibly
uncomfortable feeling I was enraged at
God for taking the one person in the
world who ever made me feel safe and I
had a long list a really long list for
god of other people who should have died
instead of her and gods like yeah that's
adorable but that's not how we're doing
it
and and I I just I just spun in rage for
months and it hurt him I mean it was not
like it was not manageable um it was it
was incredibly painful and and then
finally I remember one of my final
pieces of Rage was I am enraged at my
rage because it's interfering with my
grieving because I had some sort of idea
that my grieving would be this sort of
poetic beautiful weepy soft wood you
know minor-key music instead it was like
it was like Sid and Nancy it was just
like what's going on inside you know
just violent anger toward everybody and
everything and when I had that thought I
was given the grace of an answer and the
thought I had was I need this anger to
go so that I can grieve and then the
answer came this is your grief and grief
is the most uncomfortable experience
you'll ever have in your life and for
you is the most uncomfortable thing you
can ever feel as anger toward anybody
even a teeny tiny bit so why wouldn't
you think that your grief would come as
the most battering emotion that could
possibly happen to you I'm really
comfortable being sad I think you know
like I could do minor-key rainy-day
sweet sadness I can't handle anger and
so of course it came as anger and it and
it had it had to in order for me to feel
the the magnitude of the loss it had to
be something that was bigger than I
could hold and that's what grief is one
thing that strikes me and there are many
things that strike me but one of the
things that strikes me about you
your work of which I am a fan a big fan
is how well you use humor and lightness
along with the the difficulty and the
dumb and the darkness and I'd love to
chat about that for a minute I've read
about your I wanna call it position that
makes it sound too too strange but your
discussions of creativity and the allure
and the danger of fetishizing pain an
end for instance I've read the art of
memoir by Mary Karr which is a book I
absolutely adore which I think touches
on that also quite a lot and what I'm
wondering I'll try not to I'll try to
make this a digestible question is
through say your grieving process
certainly this this comes up in the the
moth talk there are some very funny
funny moments do you experience those or
find those in the process say of
grieving or is it something that you
unearth after the fact when you are
doing your writing or is there another
way to look at it I'm just thinking of
something that a hospice nurse said to
me because we were cracking up one day
and I can't remember what it was about
but there's a lot of anybody who's ever
been by you know there's a lot of humor
that shows up and it is literally
gallows humor you know it really is like
I've got a picture of me and and Ray's
ex-wife and Ray's ex-girlfriend who were
the two women who showed up like
champions at the end of her life to help
to take care of me and help to take care
of her because they they loved her so
much it was also just such a factor what
a boss macdaddy raya was that she had
like every woman who'd ever loved her
came back you know and and to take care
of each other and there was a lot of
laughter between the three of us about
just like handling this force of nature
as she was dying like can we survive it
right she's suck she's the opposite of a
good patient you know and
there was a lot of humor in there and
the hospice nurse was laughing was this
one day and I said I said to her it's
amazing that you can laugh given the
line of work that you're in you know um
like she said she spends her life
working with people at the worst most
painful parts of their lives at the end
of their lives and she said we have a
little motto we say if you can't laugh
at death get out of show business you
shouldn't be a hospice nurse if you
can't find if you can't let you won't
survive you know um and I'm sure that's
what you and I are talking right now in
the midst of the kovat crisis and I've
been thinking about that I've been
thinking about the the nurses that I
know and I'm imagining that you know
there's some dark ass humor happening in
those hospitals right now there there
has to be in the same way that soldiers
would tell you about the the humor that
happens when you're under fire like
there absolutely has to be or you you
just simply won't be able to survive it
so I will say that the humors they are
you know in those moments I mean right
after ray had died I mean we had been
through such hell with her and literally
I mean and her death was was not as I
say it was it was brutal you know one
minute actually she took her last breath
her last horrible breath Gigi her
ex-wife stood up brushed off her hands
and goes okay so that's done I'm gonna
be on the next flight out of here like
it's a clock you know it was hilarious
but it was also just like what Ray Oh
would have done you know because it was
like okay you guys good we good we done
here you know all like rolled over
laughing in the middle of our tears you
know and I feel like that humor has to
be shot through the entirety of your
life or else you you really are not
gonna make it through earth school
because earth schools a hard hard school
and it's a hard assignment and I I think
the humor is that is quite literally
grace you know that's these these pieces
of grace that are shot through the
nightmare yeah let's let's talk about
writing something that I'm fairly sure
that you're fond of on some level and I
was I was doing homework for this
conversation
and it seems like you decided to be a
writer very early in life
and that there there were supporting
plans but not backup plans so - so to
speak and the line that I found and you
can fact check or correct anything that
I'm I'm saying
but the Alita quote which is from an
interview did on read it forward
Arita forward comm at least and that is
something you said yourself this is what
I do and I'm willing to be a diner
waitress and a bartender and an all pair
and somebody who sells jewelry at flea
markets I'm willing not to have very
nice fancy things I'm willing to give up
going on vacation with my friends to
stay home and write I'm willing to give
up everything for this because this is
my source of light how did you know it
was your source of light what did that
feel like it felt like I've said this
before okay so I'm I would say that like
I officially launched a spiritual
journey when I was around the age of
thirty and going through a very bad
divorce that if you've heard of a book
called Eat Pray Love you already know
about a couple people read it so you
might know and I could continue that
spiritual journey in what I would call
traditional ways so prayer meditation
contemplation but until very recently so
my meditation practice has only very
very recently actually I would say only
in the last two years only since Ray had
passed has my meditation practice deep
into to a point where I might actually
say that I'm actually doing something
called meditating when I'm sitting there
rather than what I've done for the last
20 years which is sit down for 20
minutes and either think a lot or fall
asleep like that's what my meditation
practice is right thinking with your
eyes closed thinking with your eyes
closed or just flat-out falling asleep
but but every single thing that that the
scriptures and all the holy teachings
promise
promised me that I would get through
meditation I've gotten through writing
and I got that from a very early age so
the main thing is the silencing of the
mind and and it's really ironic because
you know there's a state that the
Mystics talked about going into that's
called wordless oneness where you where
your mind the chatter of the mind and
the language of the languaging centers
of the mind go silent and you feel
yourself to be quiet oneness with
everything around you um it's also
called the zone you could call it
serenity there's many names for it but I
like wordless oneness because it implies
an absence of the chatter in the mind it
is so fascinating to me that one of the
ways to drop into wordless oneness and
this has actually been studied by
neurologists is by writing you which is
ironic because that's the use of words
but it's a different it comes from a
different part of the mind
it comes from an intuitive part of the
mind more than it does from the part of
the mind that I'm using right now to
speak to you so I found from a very
early age and I was a really anxious kid
that when I was writing I could have a
vacation from what I would now call the
ego itself so the egoic self never stops
talking and it never stops complaining
there's nothing it can there's nothing
you can give it that will satisfy it
it's constantly looking for ways to be
unhappy it's constantly looking for ways
to criticize what is what is around you
and you yourself and everybody in it you
know and and that is the source of all
suffering right is that that voice but
when I would sit down and write as a kid
and to a certain extent I got it too
when I was drawing and making art but I
didn't have as much of a talent for it
my mind would quiet and and something
would happen where I would look up and
two hours would have passed and I didn't
have to be Liz
during those two hours now I didn't
can't really say that I decided to be a
writer I guess I did but
it's more like I never stopped doing
that you know I think a lot of us when
we're young when we're kids we naturally
gravitate toward creative pursuits that
make us feel still and make us feel calm
I think for many people the arts are an
intuitive natural way that human beings
as and they pick it up as children
figure out that this is a way that I can
feel good what tends to happen is that
when you reach adolescence you discover
all the other really faster hot-wired
ways to feel good which usually involves
sex or substance or spending money right
a friend of mine who's in recovery says
if it's not a martini it's a man if it's
not a man it's a MasterCard if it's not
a MasterCard something I can stuff into
myself so that I don't have to feel us I
don't have to endure the pain of being a
human being I don't have to feel my my
ego itself I it's not like I didn't do
all those things because I didn't do to
do all those things too but for some
reason I was lucky enough so a lot of
people put down the creativity when they
find the man the MasterCard the martini
the muffin
the meth what like whatever it is that
the the workaholism like whatever it is
that you're using to numb yourself so
that you don't have to feel the
creativity is a slower gentler way to do
that so when you find that the shortcut
you take it you know and a lot of people
can point to the place in their life
where they stopped creating because it's
when they found all that other stuff but
I never put it down so so for some
reason I was lucky enough to have the
good sense and a life that has been
filled with a lot of Bad's and a lot of
nonsense I I had the good sense to hold
on to that and and to notice and and
realize that it's something that made me
happy in a way that didn't come with the
great price tag that comes with those
cheap hot-wired ways to make yourself
happy and you know there's always a
hangover and a consequence from those
ways but with writing there isn't it
really was my place of of stillness and
and I think in a weird way it was the
beginning of my spiritual practice I
just didn't know that it was I didn't
have that language for it I just knew
that it felt good so let's let's pair
stillness with awe for a moment I've
also read that there are times when
you'll love a sentence so much that you
read that you'll start clapping lighters
by yourself where you happen to be
reading and I would love to know what
type of writing what writers have done
that for you if you could name even a
few of them and what it is what are the
ingredients that lead to that that one
woman standing ovation well they say
that great art has to contain two
features it has to be both surprising
and inevitable so that's the great way
that's good that's good right yeah
that's paradox is that you you have to
go oh my god I didn't see that coming
and that is the only way that could go
right I'm thinking of the ending of
Breaking Bad where we're that whole show
but like the last moments of my voice
spoiler alert
you've had many years to watch it now
people I won't tell you the ending I
will just tell you that I also stood up
and applauded at that because it felt
both surprising and inevitable so so
that's the feeling you want your whole
nervous system to kind of be like ah oh
my god I didn't I didn't know that could
be and yes of course
you know um it had to be and now it's
rearranged my DNA in a certain way where
I can't be the same now poetry tends to
do it the poets have this amazing
ability to to put that into such a tiny
space where it's like the encapsulation
of inevitability and and surprise so
I'll give you an example of one piece
that I love which is a poem by TS Eliot
called East Coker
that has gotten me through some of the
darkest times in my life some of those
moments in your life where you don't
know what to do right we're we're a
human being and this is where I think
human life gets really interesting what
happens to people when they reach the
end of their power right because
especially in this culture where we live
in a culture that says you should be
able to power through anything you know
life is it will very generously remind
you that you cannot and it will very
generously break you at times and very
generously show you as we're seeing
right now in the cove advisor so we're
like oh oh actually there's there's a
limit to our powers here and it's very
humbling and what do you do when you're
at the end of your power so that the
poem east Coker is one and it gets me
every single time how do you spell Coker
is he okay er C ke are ya East Coker and
there's a part of the poem where TS
Eliot writes weight without hope for
hope would be hope of the wrong thing
weight without love for love would be
love of the wrong thing there is yet
faith but the faith and the hope and the
love are all in the waiting wait without
thought for you are not ready for
thought and so the darkness shall be
light and the stillness the dancing
that's a stand up and applause moment
and sometimes when people I know are
grieving or they're stuck or they're
broken everything has been taken away I
will give them that poem because that
says what I don't know how to say better
than that which is right now you're
being asked to wait without hope for
anything that you hope for would be the
wrong thing and wait without love
anybody who's been going through a
horrible breakup I'll give them that
poem like you're being asked to wait
without love right now because love
would be love of the wrong thing and
anybody who's a beginning meditator I
give them that poem because of the line
wait without thought for you are not
ready for thought you don't have the
wisdom right now to have the correct
thoughts so you need to wait without
thought and then you will see if you do
that and that and they're still faith
but the
faith is in the waiting the faith isn't
waiting without hope waiting without
love waiting without thought that's the
definition of faith sitting in the
darkness in that waiting and then you'll
see how the darkness becomes light and
the stillness becomes dancing but only
every time in order to have it you've
got to give up hope and you've got to
give up love and you've got to have
faith only in the waiting so that's a
line that makes me applaud I'm another
author who gets me is well another poet
who gets me is is Walt Whitman and and
what women saying describing himself in
a song of myself describing himself as
standing both in and out of the game
watching and wondering at it and also
being involved in it that description of
he watching himself walked through life
both in and out of the game is again
something that I think of as the highest
point of enlightenment can you engage
with your life can you be involved with
your life can you feel all of the
feelings can you fall in love can you
lose can you fail can you grow can you
succeed can you buck up and also watch
it from a little bit of a detached
distance and marvel at the game itself
so that line gets me and then as far as
fiction writers go I'm I'm so in love
with Hilary mantel who wrote the wolf
halls trilogy about Henry the eighth and
won the Booker Prize for the first two
installments of it and then the third
one just came out and and the way that
I've been describing it to people is
imagine if all three Godfather movies
were as good as the first to imagine if
Godfather Part three was just as good as
one and two that's how good Hilary
mantel is that the third installment and
I'm reading that right now and I'm just
it's just a bow down moment you know as
an artist there are a lot of writers who
I look at their work and I I admire them
but I see how they did it you know
because it's almost like a carpenter
looking at another carpenters work and
being like okay see how you did the
joints there and you hid that hinge
there and that's coal I say well done
you know and then there are people I
look at their work and I'm like
I literally don't believe that you're
human
I don't understand how you can even do
this and and that's how I feel about
Hilary mantel writing about 16th century
England in a way that is so intimate and
and so that you cannot read that book
without thinking this is exactly how it
happened and and I don't know how she
does that and I'm very happy to say I'm
happy to never be able to do that I'm
just lucky to live on earth at the same
time as somebody who can well I I would
push back a little bit and I would say
that you have a rare ability to blend
readability with wordsmithing
senses that are very memorable and
really strike a chord I don't think that
is easy to do and I mean I would say you
know Kurt Vonnegut is is one who comes
to mind but it's not easy to combine
those two things and I thought it was it
was it's well I don't think it made me
crack a smile when I was reading about
you appreciating sentences and the quote
from you at the end of this this portion
of the interview was it's part of the
reason that the arts are around to
remind us that were not just here to pay
bills and die that we're also here to
get excited and feel Wonder and to feel
awe that's easy to read but it is
something that makes me go god damn
you're totally right like I need more
wonder pea too many bills too much
paperwork and so I do want to applaud
that ability and see it's yeah this it
is something that I aspire to do more of
but you're totally right or say and
you're totally right there are certain
books I'm in the middle of little big by
John Crowley which is this fantastic
goal I suppose surreal yet realistic
tale of fairies and so on and it's one
of those books where I'm like
I don't know how this guy does this at
all like I really like you have to be
another species to weave prose like this
it's just like I don't I mean this is
the thing that's so incredible about a
human life there are only two things in
the universe so far that we've
discovered that appear to be infinite
and one is the universe itself because
we haven't found the edges of it and the
other is human imagination because we
haven't found the edges of it we haven't
begun to find the edges of it it just
keeps surprising us people keep
inventing new worlds and new stories and
new I'd it's it's unbelievable and it's
not like you know it's not like people
have been sitting around not using their
imaginations for centuries everybody's
been in this game for a long time and
you would think you know you walk into
one of the massive libraries in the
world and you see all that has been
created already and you just think well
that's all been done you know and then
somebody dropped something on you and
you're like weird how how did you like
how did you find that doorway in into
that world
and it's so incredibly exciting and and
I think you know just going back again
to the idea of grief I think the the
thing that keeps me from tanking you
know is okay so the most important
person in my entire life is gone first
of all that's interesting you know like
III think that some good way to defuse
drama and trauma is to just start using
the word interesting a lot you know I
that's interesting
that's interesting like that's
interesting just on a personal level for
me that I would have said to the
universe you can you can literally do
anything and you can take anybody you
can't take this one this is the only one
I can't live about and they're like okay
that's cool honey we're gonna take that
one
you know and then I'm like wait so what
does that leave you know
well okay apparently I can live without
her because I'm being asked to and I'm
being invited to my friend Martha Beck
has a really great thing that she always
does as an account interaction to
codependence she likes to take classical
sort of sappy love songs that are about
codependence and just add one line to
them to make them to put them into
context and so she'll take that song for
instance this is one of my favorites
should go I can't live if living is
without you and yet here I sit eating a
sandwich it's like apparently I can I
can't live if living is about you
because here I said eating a sandwich
like life is going on but what keeps me
here is is first of all I'm hungry and
I'm gonna go eat a sandwich and and and
the body wants to keep continue living
and secondly I want to see what happens
next you know I want to see what happens
next it's a really interesting world
where we have not yet met the limits of
consciousness the limits of creativity
and the limits of invention and the
limits of imagination and I don't want
to miss it
so my curiosity I think is is it's going
to always be the thing that did it wins
so there's the curiosity there's the
serendipity then there's the the
organizing and the planning and I'd love
to bounce between those two sides of the
spectrum let's talk about the organizing
for a second and maybe we could start
with mister Kisco I think that's your
nice do you use do you still use an
index card or no card system during
research could you describe what your
system looks like please and I suppose
we should probably explain to mr. Kisker
as to let's you know what I think it'd
be funnier just not to
just let you all just let that be the
mystery in the back no I would be happy
to explain mr. Kisco as you all should
know by now it was my ninth grade social
studies teacher and I can't believe that
only Tim knows that and not not the rest
of you was ninth grade Western Civ
teacher and really hard-ass really good
teacher really scary teacher and he
taught us how to write term papers and
he taught this system that was very
simple that involved index cards and a
box to put the index cards in and as
you're doing your research on the topic
you put divisions in the box on
different subjects and then every time
you find a fact or a piece of
information on a page you would write
one fact per index card one piece of
information per index card and then
there was an also system that you would
use for footnoting so like if the first
book the first book I would read would
be book a so at the bottom of the index
card I would write a and then the page
that I found it on so a 23 right so and
then when I went to the next book it
would be B page 46 right so that way you
can mix up the cards and you can still
remember where everything came from very
simple and and then each card gets one
fact only and each fact goes in the
filing system under whatever subject
whatever area is and when you start to
write you've got all your facts at your
fingertips in order I've taken that
system which was used for researching
and I've I've grown it into a system
that I use for writing my novels because
my novels are very research-based and so
for instance this recent novel but I
just wrote called city of girls that
takes place in New York City in the
1940s in the theater world
I'm involves a young woman who moves to
New York City in 1940 and gets pulled
into a group of showgirls and dancers
and Playboy's and actors and goes on a
wild promiscuity bender just as the war
is about to begin for America that book
required an enormous amount of research
to be able to speak the language of the
1940s to be able to write a play there's
a there's
musical butts in the middle of the book
and I had to figure out like get the
language of playwriting of the 1940s
correct how did people dress what were
they wearing what was going on in the
news at the time and so I would get a
big shoe box and and a bunch of index
cards and just dive into the research
which took me about three or four years
and I would read a lot of biographies
and a lot of letters and every single
idea and every single fact got its own
card so every time I had a line of
dialogue that I wanted to put in the
play into the book I would write it on
its own card and I would put it for that
character into their little section
every time I found out something about I
had a little section called fashion
1940s right so every time I found any
tiny little detail I would put it into
that section that was about fashion any
time I had a detail about like sex for
instance I I needed to kind of figure
out what the sexual culture was of New
York City in the 1940s what kind of
birth control were people using how were
they talking about sex so anything I
found on there put in the to the sex
section anything I found out about what
it was like working at the Brooklyn
Naval Yards in the 1940s during the war
because my character ends up working
there would go into the Navy Yard
section so so it's all very tidy and
organized in box after box after box and
I by the time it's done it's like I've
got a novel I call it a novel a book in
a box but it's really usually five boxes
by then but it's such a great gift
because when you're writing and it
really helps you it really helps me with
writer's block because as I'm
introducing a new character into the
story all I have to do is reach into the
box and pull out her file and because
I've been putting notes in there for the
last four years I've got like a 2-inch
thick file on this character of details
of things she would say or what she's
wearing or ideas for character
development and and so it's an
assistance to myself when I sit down to
write that I can draw upon that and use
it and it makes it so so so much easier
and sometimes the research is tedious
but I part of my sense of stewardship
and friendship over myself is that I try
to do really nice things for Liz
I try to do really nice things for
future Liz you know like I hate flossing
my teeth but I do it for future Liz as a
gift so everything I like I hate I hate
this but future Liz this is for you obey
because I care about you and I love you
and like and so when I'm writing these
notes to myself so I might be sitting
there at the New York Public Library
doing research on like how much theater
productions cost in the 1940s and and
you know how many sets how much the sets
would have costed who would have been on
hit like boring stuff you know but I was
just sit there and I'll find some really
great detail and I'll write it on a card
and I'll be like oh my god future Liz is
gonna be so psyched when she finds this
card three years from now because she's
gonna be writing the scene and she's
gonna be stuck and she's gonna reach in
and she's gonna pull out this detail and
she's gonna be like ah yes like so and
then what happens is that while I'm
writing
I'll reach in and I'll find some amazing
card with a great piece of dialogue on
it or a great detail that really helps
with the singing and I'll be like thanks
passed Liz you know it's like this
little salute across time we're like
passes like I got you babe and future
Liz is like thank you for looking out
for me you're the best so like all of
the preparation that I do is to help
myself during the hard part which is the
creative the actual creating a novel and
I want to give myself all the help I can
because I want to suffer the least I
possibly can so I really do try to like
really show up for future Liz it's it
strikes me that you have a very
productive at times at least of course I
don't know every detail of your entire
life but balance between this sort of
egoless or ego less at least meaning
less ego wordless oneness and then the
very sort of egoic by necessity planning
side of things right where you're
actually you're actually creating
multiple Liz's to help okay do help sort
of clear the decks and and steer the
ship
when you look at say your five boxes of
cards whether it's for the fiction like
city of girls or nonfiction what
percentage of what you have on those
cards ends up making it into finished
books would you say I'm curious kind of
what makes the cut eventually Tim I am
so happy to tell you that I can give you
that percentage because I can see it
very clearly because once I pull a card
out I put it into its own separate box
once it's done so when I'm finished I
can actually see how many I used and I'm
really interested in that myself and it
is about 1/5 1/5 makes it into the book
yeah yeah yeah good person I think
that's a good strikes me as a good
percentage you know and you definitely
need all of it because you don't know
what you're gonna need right you want to
kind of over prepare and and and you
know all of it I like what you're saying
about the the bifurcation of selves of
the egoic less wordless wonder creator
and the one who's preparing but I
actually think that that there's a
there's an egolessness that's in the
research as well and that is the
humility of feeling like I am a servant
to this book you know I'm you know I
really do feel and you know this if
you've read big magic that ideas come to
us from a very mysterious outer source
and by mysterious I mean we will never
know why it is that ideas are formed
that ideas as I like to think of my
ideas are these bodyless gigabytes of
consciousness and they have desire and
they have will and they want to be made
manifest and anyone who's ever had an
idea knows this the idea itself has an
urgency to it it wants to be born it
wants to be nourished it won't leave you
alone right it's waking you up in the
middle of the night it's nagging at you
it's sending coincidences to you and and
serendipitous you know reminders of it
and it just it just starts to become a
sort of an
obsession it's it's almost a viral
infection of an idea coming to you and
taking you over I think it's such an
honor to be given an idea especially if
it's a halfway decent one that I feel
like my life is in service to that and
and when I don't have an idea and I
don't have a thought for a book I think
of myself I'd the image that I hold of
myself is is literally of a servant like
one of those very proud British servants
you know who doesn't see their servitude
as as being demeaning as sees it as a
great as a great craft a great skill to
be a good servant right I see myself in
uniform white gloves hands behind my
back standing outside the door of the
news at attention waiting you know I'm
like wait it's not passive I'm like
waiting for the next idea to come and so
that I can be of service to it and be
ready for it when it arrives and so so
there's a certain yeah there's a certain
humility in the research process to of
just I'm just working for the mothership
you know I don't and I don't know what
the mothership is I don't know where the
ideas come from but I am a grateful
servant to it it's it that this may seem
like a forced segue but I'm gonna force
it anyway I don't think it's forced
you're mentioning being of service a
number of things have come up grieving
death this active waiting if I could
give it that phrasing one book that came
up in my research and feel free to
confirm or deny because you can't
believe everything you read on the
internet but are you a fan of
meditations by Marcus Aurelius yes why
is that what is the meaning of this book
for you or what what does it play for
you
okay so Marcus Aurelius was of course
the great philosopher king you know
Plato had always said that the ideal
Society would be a society where the
king was also a philosopher we have that
right now in America
I was excited to see where that was gone
I I kid I kid because I love um anyway
Marcus Aurelius was that he was he was a
great scholar and he was a great leader
and and he was like all philosophers
somebody who spent his life in
examination of the human condition and
and of his own existence and his
meditations are what survives of his
journals and they're so beautiful and
they're so immediate I mean the other
thing that great art is is that it's
eternal right so the way that Marcus
Aurelius speaks to himself in his
journal feels like it could have been
written yesterday he is struggling
through the same eternal questions that
all of us are struggling through what is
the meaning of my life how do i how do I
serve without being destroyed and
service how do I handle failure how do I
handle difficult people how do I handle
the limits of my powerlessness you know
what happens when there are situations
that are beyond my control and and he
was a stoic as well so a lot of it is
just about can I survive my emotions
can I and and stoicism in that
philosophical realm doesn't mean you
know white-knuckling your way through
pain and pretending not to feel it means
achieving going back to Whitman
achieving that sense of being both in
and out of the game at the same time
being being involved and like up to your
neck in the messiness of life well at
the same time achieving a tiny bit of
detachment to watch the I guess what the
in Eastern philosophy they would call
the karmic dilemma that you're in and
recognizing that there may be
limitations to how much you can control
that and I love the way that he speaks
to himself directly in his journals the
way that he that he'll say to himself
come on come on man like come on Marcus
you know like dude get it together like
it's time like this is a moment for you
to act
you can go down now or you can find your
strength you could find your resilience
like the way that he coaches himself I
find that incredibly inspiring and and I
also think my friend Martha back who I
talk about a lot because she's a great
teacher but she has a great a great
teaching that she gives people when
they're full of anxiety and full of fear
there's ways that you can learn to speak
to yourself that will actually mitigate
that and one of the ways that she
teaches is that she tells her coaches
for clients to write down let their fear
speak so you just give your fear it's
it's day right you have to respect it it
exists it's part of you you don't want
to cast it away or attack it you just
open up your journal and you invite your
fear to write down everything that it's
afraid of and you listen politely and
with the non-violent compassion to your
fear as it speaks and then once it's
done and it's had it say you say thank
you so much for sharing that I'm really
I'm really grateful to that you trust me
enough to be this vulnerable and to tell
me everything that you're afraid of and
then you say to your fear I'm now going
to ask you now that you've had a chance
to speak if you'll step aside and I'm
going to bring another aspect of myself
forward and I'm going to ask it to speak
so if fear if you would just step aside
for a moment I'm now inviting wisdom
into the room and now I'm going to ask
wisdom to write down what it thinks and
what it suggests in this case and it's
extraordinary to see the wisdom that
people find in themselves that you're
not just made of fear you're also made
of grace and of wisdom and those
meditations of Marcus Aurelius it feels
like that's what he's doing
you know he's writing to himself from a
place of fear anxiety and uncertainty
and then he's writing back to himself
from a place of wisdom and saying okay
this is okay you this is what you're
upset about I recognize that I see that
and now I'm going to ask wisdom to come
into the room and this is what it would
suggest so it's so beautiful and
intimate you know to get to see a great
mind like that working with itself and
in such intimate setting
well hot damn am I glad I asked about
marcus aurelius and for people who have
no familiarity with marcus aurelius
to put the philosopher label also in
perspective from the leadership or
within the sort of mesh of leadership he
was the last of the rulers known as the
five good emperors and also the last
emperor of the Pax Romana which was an
age of peace and stability in the Roman
Empire so it's a very highly effective
highly revered and also highly
reflective and so I definitely second
the recommendation I would suggest thank
you so much Tim for putting him into of
course because I'm so fascinated by
spirituality and philosophy I forgot to
mention that he was also a badass Roman
Emperor he was excellent at it so yes
thank you for pointing that out it
wasn't just a release awful guy he was
also running like the world's greatest
empire and he was having fascinating
character and in some ways a reluctant
leader also much like Cincinnatus and
some others who want George Washington
comes to mind fascinating fascinating
guy and I would love to leapfrog to
Martha Beck because you mentioned this
parts work it would it would be one way
to put it letting the fear speak which
makes me think also something called
internal family systems or ifs which
super-super i'll use the word
interesting and also incredibly
effective I've seen I've seen ifs mostly
as used by Michael and Annie MIT Hoffer
who are therapists who work very closely
with a nonprofit called maps in
developing protocols for mdma-assisted
psychotherapy for PTSD and
both ifs and well I don't want to
actually say this about ifs but
cognitive behavioral therapy has a lot
of its roots in stoic philosophy which
has been used for trauma and PTSD and
then ifs does as well that's just as a
bit of contact for folks and I'd love
for you to speak to what else you have
learned from Martha Beck and what are
some of the other things really stuck
for you yeah well I'll give you I'll
give you one she's when I met her I met
her years ago at an Oprah Winfrey event
she when if you don't know if her she's
a life coach she's a writer
she's actually the person for whom the
term life coach was invented she was the
original life coach and and I always say
she was Oprah Winfrey's life coach
everybody so if you just want to just
want to know like some credentials
that's Martha and Minh I met her I met
her around the time Raya was sick I had
I had reached out to her weird not there
are no coincidences but we had we had
met years ago and then she wrote a book
called Diana herself that landed on my
desk and I read it and I was like this
is so dazzling and and I need to reach
out to her personally and tell her how
great it is
so that reestablished our contact with
each other and then very shortly after
that contact was established Array got
sick and Martha was right there for us
and really walking us through that and
that that that death and dying
experience in such a remarkable way I
can truly say that I it would have been
a very much more painful experience
without her help one of the things that
I said to Raya about Martha once I first
started having conversations with her
was I said I've always felt like I play
the game of life pretty well Martha took
the ball and just left the arena like
here I am struggling to play the game
well she's just like now I'm not even
gonna play the game by his rules and and
I didn't even know that you could just
leave the game and and she's so wild off
the charts and her wildness is that she
has this
a strong belief that your intuitive
nature will take care of everything but
in order to listen to it you have to
step away from trauma and you have to
step away from culture and that often
means you have to unlearn every single
thing you are ever taught by your family
and by your culture about what is right
and wrong and you have to become a
completely natural wild intuitive being
and you have to guide yourself purely
based on essentially what she would say
is based on what your body tells you so
anytime that you and that's located like
by putting my hand on it right now but
it's that center located between like
your navel and your sternum that's often
extremely emotionally reactive so if I
don't want to do something if I don't
like somebody that thing knows it's like
a it's it's a compass that's never wrong
and culture and trauma and family and
training have taught me to override it
constantly right so somebody invites me
to an event and I my sternum navel area
starts to feel sick
because I don't want to do it but my
training and my culture tells me that I
have to
that's me overriding the only
navigational system that is truly my own
in order to be a good member of society
and/or it's my fear that's overriding it
because I say oh I have to say yes to
that invitation because I have to
network you know and if I say no to this
really powerful person then you know it
so and that overrides it anytime you say
yes with your mind when your body says
no you will lead yourself farther and
farther and farther away from your path
and so the work that Martha does is
about teaching people how to trust that
and only that and she has navigated her
life based on that and only that
and she started navigating it that way
not for fun but because she was dying
she was literally dying of several auto
immune diseases and she was dying of
being a good person she was dying of
doing everything exactly right as she
had been taught by her Mormon upbringing
and then by Harvard she went and got
three degrees at Harvard so she went
from one really oppressive culture which
was Mormonism into another one which was
academia and the entire time was trying
to be the best good moral ethical person
as per cultures recommendations and she
was literally dying of it and the way
that she cured herself was that she went
on what she called an integrity cleanse
and this is the most badass thing I have
ever heard anybody do this is that is
amazing yeah it all sounds good until
you find out what you have like true for
so many things like she like she got a
watch she got a digital watch this was
years ago before phones you can do it
now on your phone but like you know ask
yourself if you really want to but she
did it because her alternative was
literally to die you know and that's
often what will make people have to
change she put it she got this watch she
touched she put a timer on it to have it
go off every 30 minutes and every 30
minutes whatever she was doing she would
check and see if she was lying and if
she was lying she'd correct it so every
30 minutes every 30 minutes so that
means you're on the phone with your
sister and your sister saying you guys
coming for Christmas this year and you
say yeah I can't wait we're so looking
forward to actually no I don't want to
come I don't want to come we're not
coming next 30 minutes another one
beep-beep-beep everything every single
interaction every single conversation no
more polite social lies nothing this
extreme integrity cleanse and she said
it was the most amazing thing in the
world she lost every single member she
lost her marriage she lost like she lost
the the work path that she was on and
what she became was herself and what she
got back was her health
her well-being and her intuition and her
instincts and then she had a few people
left at the end of that and they were
her core people and from that she built
her entire new life that she's still
living in now so it's a massively badass
thing to do but it's pretty cool and she
she said you know I've softened it a bit
she's like I'll tell a social lie now
just to be nice but but it's munoz got a
new book coming out next year that's
that's all about this that I can't wait
to be out into the world because it's so
yeah the amount of integrity that she
lives with and the amount of integrity
that she taught me to live with are huge
and when you asked me you know was it
hard for me to tell my husband that I
was in love with Rhea that was directly
a result of seeing the way that Martha
lives and and just having to be in
integrity and at the same time as being
in respect to somebody I'll give you one
more Martha Beck line that I love she
says there are certain moments of your
life where you where you're standing in
front of a bonfire and you have to jump
you just have to jump into it and you
have to be willing to burn away
everything that you've been taught and
everything that you're afraid of and
just do it and she said and I remember
her telling me this was such Glee she
goes it's such a cool moment that you're
in and and and she said this to me
you know as I was leaving my marriage
and going to be with Reyes she said that
that these bonfire moments are so
fantastic because there's only two
things that can happen when you jump
into a bonfire one of them is that you
find out that it wasn't actually a
bonfire that you were afraid that it was
going to burn you to pieces and and it
actually didn't it wasn't as scary as
you thought you did it you took the leap
it turned out to be kind of like warm
and soft and easy so it was no big deal
the other thing that can happen is that
it is a bonfire and you are incinerated
and your entire life is incinerated by
it and that's even better because then
you get to be reborn as a Phoenix on the
other side completely new so either way
you win so there's no reason not to ya
mule either jump in and find out it was
nothing or you'll jump in and you'll be
destroyed and that's awesome too
when I say when I say Martha doesn't
play by the game that's that's what I
mean like that's what he's not even in
the arena that we would all any sort of
normal way of living
right that reason she's been you know
one of the top three most influential
people it's like you're like Martha do
we go left left right or straight she's
like we go up you're like what how do we
do that
that's incredible let's talk about the
integrity check that sternum to navel
area we'll have to come up with some
sort of perineum like label that makes
it a little easier I think is a better
compass there we go yeah when you do say
an integrity check and I had read that
when Raya was sick for instance you
began deleting or archiving emails
without responding as a bit of a treat
to yourself yes I'm not okay deleting
goodbye and when you say now check in
with yourself and decide to say no to
something let's just to make it easy or
make it concrete via email you get an
invitation from a friend you do actually
really like with something it could
plausibly advance your career or be fun
but you check in with yourself and it's
like no this isn't this isn't this isn't
a yes how do you phrase your nose or
declines do you have any particular
go-to language that you'd like to use um
I just want to Claire
I want to make sure everybody knows that
this is not easy
I don't want to have any illusions for
anybody that this is simple and the
closer the relationship the harder it is
that the closer and more intimately I'm
involved with somebody the more stakes
there are for me and the harder it is
for me to tell the truth and that feels
like it should be you know there's a
paradox
you know the people you love the most
should be the people that you are able
to be the most honest with well no
because they're the people who you want
to hurt the least right um and and so
that's that's where it's really really
hard so there's a couple layers of it
right so if it's somebody I now treat my
inbox like it's my home because I think
it's an extension of my home so if
somebody walks into my home uninvited
and announces themselves and doesn't say
how they got a key and and asks for
something I delete that email and I will
delete that email even if they are a
producer for good morning you know I'm
like I'm I'm just like I didn't invite
you in there are proper channels you
know what they are I don't know how you
got my personal email and I just I just
delete it and and if I feel a sense in
my sternum of a fence of feeling like
this person has taken the liberty I
don't believe that I owe them anything I
don't believe that I owe them anything
anymore than if I came down to my
kitchen and saw people sitting at my
table who I didn't know eating breakfast
I wouldn't believe that I owed that to
make them a cup of coffee oh I don't
even think I owe them a polite response
I owe them nothing I I didn't ask you to
come into my house I don't owe you
anything
so that's the easiest those are ones who
are easy and I now treat myself to doing
that
I mean I do that every day I clear my
inbox out very quickly that way and then
it's very I'm entertained when they come
back later and they're like just
circling back and I'm like yeah just
deleting you again circle back as many
times as you want you are not coming in
so that's simple
it's just bumping this up because I know
you and I'm just it's like whack-a-mole
zits like I can do this all day
delete delete delete if it's if it's
somebody who I care about if it's
something that I'm that I that I'm
interested in but I'm just not going to
do it because I don't want to I will
write back and say thank you so much I'm
really honored that you invited me to
this but I'm not going to be able to do
this at this time and I don't feel a
need to give a reason I think a simple
no is is really really good and the
reason sometimes the reason it's good
not to give an explanation is that if
that person is an expert manipulator as
many of us are that explanation will not
suffice so it won't matter what you give
as an explanation because they can come
back and be like well we can do it by
audio you know we can do if you're oh
well we can do it a different weekend
just know and I learned a lot about this
from my teacher Byron Katie who teaches
an amazing thing called the school for
the work that's a whole she's a whole
nother I'm another extraterrestrial
force she's extraterrestrial she is not
she is the only fully enlightened human
being I can I I believe I have ever met
and as such she does not have any
trouble saying an honest yes and
announce no to people and just just just
to underscore that excited a and in
person training with her I mean
literally no hesitation no no struggle
no conflict it's bizarre and just
mesmerizing to watch it really loves you
there's also no hostility so no offense
no hostilities her somebody came up to
her an event handed her a book that
they'd written which people do to me all
the time too so I really marveled at
this and they said they said I wrote
this and I want to share with you and
she said oh sweetheart I'm never gonna
read that
true it's just true I've never heard
that and I'm like oh my god I didn't
know you could say that right it's so
that's amazing and she said it's so
lovingly like oh yeah no I no interest
in meeting that so she teaches I don't
know if you did when you took her
training did you do where she teaches a
simple no and she doesn't training how
to give a simple no I don't think we
actually spent much time on that so I
would love to hear you say more so it's
we worked on the emotional 1 pages and
the turnarounds you did a lot on the
turnarounds which which is probably we
could do a whole episode just on that
but and if you have the means and if you
have the chance to ever take her 9 day
school for the work it's the most it's
the most important thing I've ever done
for myself so oh wow
say that quite simply but she has a
whole day in the nine day school for
work which is about the simple now and
the simple no is ways to say no and and
it always begins with thank you and
there's never a but she because she
feels that the word but is very cruel
and and it's just an and so it's thank
you and no and and that's it that's a
simple note and then if they come back
you can say well hold on just a pause
perfect is that literally the phrasing
or is it just yeah and it still makes my
stomach ache because I'm like oh my god
you can't just do that you've gotta give
you've gotta like do the dance and she's
like you don't have to do the dance and
and she's the one who taught me if the
person is a good enough manipulator it
doesn't matter what you bring but
they're gonna manipulate it alright and
and the beautiful thing about a simple
know is that it gives in the jujitsu
game it gives somebody no weapon that
they can take and bring back at you they
can say you're being incredibly selfish
and you can say I hear that and you
might be right about that that's another
one she always says you might be right
about that you might be right about that
and no and you just keep adding and no
after the statement so then there's um
you know I
but you know I really I need you to do
this I'm I'm desperate and you say I see
that I see your desperation and now and
and one other thing she'll add is you
can say if I change my mind about this
I'll let you know and and and no and
that's been a game changer for me so I
just did one last week somebody who I
have a professional relationship said I
want you to do this I want you to do
this one-hour video interview to promote
this thing that I'm doing and and old
Liz would have thought I owe her that
because she did this other thing for me
that time and I checked in with my inner
compass and I was like nothing in me
wants to do this and so I just wrote
back to her I said I'm so sorry I'm not
I said I'm sorry and I'm not going to be
able to do this at this time and she
wrote back and pushed in and said oh let
me clarify I wasn't clear about why we
need it we really need it because right
now you know it's really hard for us to
sell things because we don't have
because of kovat 19 and and it's just a
you know that's that's why we need it
and I wrote back and said I I hear you
and I understand you and no and and it
it goes away they're you know they they
don't tend to come back a third time you
know it really it really does just stop
um and let it sit at the know the more
words you add after that the more
entangled you get but again I I want to
make clear it's it's it's hardest
closest to home and it's hardest with
family and and with family I find if I
anticipate that I'm gonna be asked
something I really have to practice I
really because it's scary and I have to
I have to really practice and be like
and just practice saying I'm not doing
that right now I'm not coming this year
I'm not doing you know and I'll say it a
thousand times just go for a long walk
and I'll just practice it and practice
it and practice it because as I say that
the closer the people aren't to you the
more difficult it is you know the
as a bit of personal digression here I
was working on a book an entire book
about saying no this past summer and the
the great irony of course is that I came
up with all the reasons why I shouldn't
write the book in the process of putting
it together but what I noticed as I was
practicing different ways of saying no
is that it's an incredibly clarifying
exercise because it in a sense it kind
of brings to surface the the true
character of many people you know or
people who are attempting to reach you
and what what I found surprising and
maybe I shouldn't have found it
surprising is that many of my close
friends would repay today upset would
respond with you know dude good for you
or for respecting your boundaries that's
a great line rock on and they they got
it and they were just like oh I wish you
know I could say that more myself like
good for you and it was the it was the
bonfire that wasn't a bonfire in those
cases haha uh-huh did you ever run into
a bonfire that was 104 sure absolutely
and then I'm like oh wow because if you
would I would I what I like about what
you said about the or these sort of
jujitsu analogy is that if you provide
really specific reasons for why you
can't do it and you elaborate you've
just created a potential negotiation
right right but if if you if you don't
provide that grip that toehold then one
of the few responses someone can give
you if they're upset and still want to
push is some type of personal ad hominem
attack or an accusation and then you're
like oh wow okay now it's that kind of
party okay this is this is this is good
too this is good to know before we're on
stage having a public TIFF at god knows
what I mean this is this is valuable
information so there were definitely
some bonfires
and basically people to self-immolated
right because I was like oh wow you've
just proved my internal compass to be
extremely accurate right this is the
reason and here is the reason I'm not
working with you just say that you don't
know it you just know it because the
body knows first the body knows first
but only always only always and and it's
and it's the one of the things that
Martha says that I love is she's like
because culture and civilization have
overwritten the software system of the
body so much and told you that you don't
trust that what you trust are the rules
and the mores and the the fear-based
scarcity based you know grasping this is
how you have to act this is who you have
to be in order to be safe and mean why
our bodies like you you know like ooh
gross or on the opposite side like yummy
like mmm that's I wouldn't be over there
I want to be with those people you know
I don't want to be with these people and
and she said you know and if you think
about it like the wisdom of the body is
so incredible to such an amazing machine
it's such a fantastic machine and it's
ancient it's it's been honed by
literally millions and millions and
millions of years of evolution into this
phenomenal machine of reception of
conscious reception of being able to
respond and being able to know the mind
thinking mind is brand-new it's the
newest update it's only a hundred
thousand maybe two hundred thousand
years old it's got a lot of bugs in it
and and I think of the best example of
this is if you were to break your femur
snap your femur in half the biggest bone
in the human body if it's properly set
that thing's healed in six weeks and and
you're walking back on it your body
knows what to do if somebody tells you
you're fat or that you're stupid forty
years ago it still hurts now right like
these wounds the the mental and
emotional body
mind doesn't know how to heal itself
nearly as well as the body does it's so
vulnerable and the body is so much
stronger and so what Martha says is that
if you are given this amazing body
that's this incredible antenna of
operating in the world and always
knowing what's right for it and what's
wrong for it and you override it with
the mind
essentially it's as if you've been given
the brand-new fanciest like highest
speed operating thinnest MacBook Air and
you're using it as a placemat just you
don't know how to use it right so that's
what the body is it's like this machine
that you've been given but if you if you
you're just eating your cereal off of it
and thinking that you're you know and
it's like no open it up and start using
it because it's never wrong it's never
ever ever wrong and and it's it's a
tricky thing it's especially tricky
thing to to tell two people who have
been addicts because nobody trust their
intuition less than anybody who's been
through addiction because they're like
you know you don't want me doing what my
body wants me you don't want me saying
yes to what my body's but but there's a
really big difference between addiction
and intuition and and if you look back
at your moments of addiction or your
moments where you're out of control of
yourself you usually can find that your
intuition was trying to tell you
something and your addiction was
overriding it right um your intuition
knew that this was not a good move but
your mind your the the the addictive
broken diseased mind was giving you
instructions so so truly the intuition
can be trusted I know it's so hard for
us to believe but it does know does know
right from wrong for you I could not
agree more if I look back at the biggest
just to maybe contain the scope the
biggest business disasters or
partnerships I knew on day one that it
was a bad idea or there was something
there was something I felt that
indicated discomfort and I over wrote it
right every single one there there was
there
there was a a somatic sense that
something was crooked or off before I
signed on the dotted line
I mean every single time so how many
people do you know who said I knew the
night before my wedding that I that this
was a mistake
how many people do you know say that and
and yet why did you do it because you
were 29 and it was time to get married
you know because you'd been raised in a
culture that said this is what you do
now because the invitations had been
sent out because 300 people had gathered
because you'd spent your family spent
$30,000 on the wedding like whatever the
reasons were you knew somewhere in that
in that sternum area you know and how
much you had to drink that day in order
to override that home whatever you had
to do in order to shut down that compass
that was saying uh uh you know it's it's
brutal
you know it's brutal but um but yeah
that that's the work of the second half
of my life I can say that now that I'm
50 that the only thing I'm interested
anymore is that let me ask you a
question that maybe leading us to a dead
end but I'll ask nonetheless just
because it keeps coming up in the sort
of deeper currents like if you're sort
of kayaking on top of a pond and you see
the the currents shifting the opposite
direction from the top level of the
water the surface level this keeps
popping up for me and I'll ask and then
we can edit it out if it doesn't go
anywhere yeah this could be this could
be like a lot of lead-up for terrible
punchline but do you have any
perspective on psychedelics do you have
any thoughts at all related to
psychedelics yeah yeah I would love to
talk about that I do and I've done it
and I've done it recently and I've done
it in controlled settings with people
who you know are good at it
I've done it with shamans and I've
gotten a lot out of it
I've also stopped doing it recently so
I'm happy to talk about both of those
things and and I don't think that that
should be a condemnation for anybody's
exploration of this I I think those
substances are really fascinating
my experience of it was exactly as
promised that it will open up your
entire consciousness where you can move
through time and space you can see
things that you never could have seen
otherwise I was given I had one journey
with the shamans help during the time of
Raya dying that really truly gave me
what I needed a piece of information
that I needed to get me through to the
end of her life that I think I would
have broken if I hadn't been shown that
piece of information and I and I brought
the shaman in specifically because I
said I'm at the end of myself and I need
a vision I I can't I can't sort this out
myself this is beyond my capacity and I
think it's beyond the capacity of
counselors
I need a divine I need a divine vision I
need to see into some other realm on
this because this world is not providing
the answer and I got it and and it was
essential I also had an experience of
being told things and shown things in
that state that turned out later not to
be true and so I know that you can also
you have to be careful I also had the
experience of just basically just
getting high you know just basically
getting high with my friends and having
us think that we were having divine
visions from God but really we were just
up and and really we were just
like basically we weren't much more than
highschool sophomores sitting around
being like you know I think the universe
is and and and thinking that we were
having these really profound experiences
and then later when sobriety came being
like oh we were just hi so all of that
needs to be taken into account I think
and and I've also seen people think that
they were great healers and great
spiritual leaders and be a little bit
deceived in that and lead people into
stuff that maybe they weren't ready for
I think it's very hard to take a Western
mind and try to make it into a 14th
century Peruvian people go on ayahuasca
journeys then they go to Colombia and
they think that's what's gonna happen
there's a lot the the rot is deep in the
Western mind there's a lot of ego
there's a lot to untangle and so if you
bring an egoic mind into a sacred circle
I think you can go in some possibly
mistaken directions okay all of that is
to say people do what you want and do
what you think is best for you and and
follow your own intuition on it I
followed my own intuition into
psychedelics and then I followed my own
intuition out of it and I don't regret
having done it I may I may do it again
it's not a fully closed door it's just
that right now in my life I'm at a place
where I want to have a clear mind and
and I want to see whether I can manage
to negotiate my life without being
altered in any way and so I've stopped
drinking and I've stopped I've stopped
doing anything that alters my mind um
again that might not be forever it's
just that's where I'm at as of this
moment so that's my very long answer to
your question but but I have I do think
it's I do think they're remarkable
powerful substances I've had great
things come out of them for me and I'm
taking a break from it thank you for
answering that yeah it's just sort of a
whisper I wanted to pay attention to so
thank you for answering that I will
underscore Dogma on it like really
really really and I may even do it again
someday but just just not for now okay
wait a little too far with it I was like
I'm just kidding
up now this is like you just have
to be really accountable to yourself
about are you using this are you using
this for transformation or are using
this for escape and and you know only
you can know that yeah it's I do want to
underscore a few things that you said
since this is subject an area that I
spend a lot of time thinking about have
for the last six years or so that these
are very very powerful compounds and
they create a plasticity that can be
molded for the better it can also be
molded for the worse and there are just
bus loads there are arena loads full of
charlatans who have Messiah Complex who
believe themselves to be able to reach
into your soul and fix what is broken
who have you know who have no no track
record no credibility no training that
would lend itself to that type of
confidence and you wouldn't go on
Craigslist to find a someone to perform
neuro surgery on you and I would I would
suggest particularly if you are
psychedelically naive meaning you have
not used these compounds that you take
it that seriously and that might seem
like a very an overstatement but I don't
think it is because there's there is a I
found tremendous value in psychedelics
over the years over the past 20 years
and nonetheless I like to be a voice of
caution because there's a survivorship
bias with the positive stories if that
makes sense it's kind of like the mutual
funds you read about in Barron's it's
like yeah those are the ones that have
survived but if you have a you know
saying a thousand orangutangs flick
flipping quarters like eventually or
like one of them might have flipped
heads that would be that would that
would be very visually arresting though
that's kind of a that's kind of the
screensaver I want on my computer but so
just say people should be cautious and
and particularly if you have no
experience to take it very seriously and
and and people will do whatever they're
going to do people are gonna do whatever
they do keep at the very at the very
least if you are considering that type
of tool I would suggest that you start
with at least a month of daily
meditation and possibly journaling which
is what I would like to ask you about
next because we've we've mentioned
letting your fear speak we've mentioned
that in the in the context of Martha
Beck and I read that every few years you
go through the artists way course and I
just love to hear how you decide when it
is time to do that and what role morning
pages have for you if you could speak to
that yeah and if people don't know what
the artists way is it's um it's a
wonderful course that was created 20
years ago 25 years of those yeah at
least one evening Julia Cameron and it's
it's a it's it's it's based on the
12-step recovery program actually and
but it's a way of recovering your
creativity from its trauma and brené
Brown has talked about this too a lot
about what what we call art scars that
people have some very good reason you
know many many people were mocked for
their creative endeavors when they were
children and they shut it down and or
you were told that you can never make a
living out of this this isn't a
responsible way to live this is for
children put these you know put away
your childish things and take on the
mantle of adulthood and and so it's a
12-week long course self-guided course
where she leads you through a series of
questions and exercises that are meant
to liberate your inner artist from their
wounds
and and it's also one of the the two
foundations of the artists way are the
morning pages which is every morning you
wake up and you write for three pages
anything no matter what as soon as you
wake up and the second thing is the
artists date that once a week you take
yourself on a date to something
interesting alone that you that you go
do whatever it is it could be anything
from going to an art gallery to taking a
walk in a part of town that you've never
seen before just some something that you
do that is entirely your own I've said
this before and I'll say it again Eat
Pray Love would not exist without the
artists way I was in a terrible
depression and in a lot of pain and a
lot of emotional suffering and going
through a divorce and somebody gave me
the artist way and I did it and one of
the things that happens when you do it
is that various ways she asks on almost
every single exercise she's asking you
various interpretations of if there was
one talent that you wish you had you
know what would it be if there was one
skill that you would love to learn what
would it be if there's something you
wish you had studied when you were
younger what is it if there's if you
could have five you know talents that
you don't have now what might they be if
you could have five and she keeps asking
these questions in various ways and you
answer them again and again and again
and when you're done doing the artists
way you go back then you read through
all your journals and you see what keeps
showing up because that's your clue as
to what the next direction of your life
was and when I did it what kept showing
up was apparently I really want to learn
how to speak Italian because it was on
almost every page it's like I wish I
could speak Italian I wish I could speak
ten and I and this is the beautiful
thing about the way that the mind hides
things from us I literally didn't know
that about myself
I had no idea that it was such a big
deal in my life that apparently my
consciousness really wanted to learn how
to speak Italian so for no reason
whatsoever I just started taking Italian
lessons um at night and in in night
school at the new school Social Research
in New York which I call night school
for divorced ladies because it was all a
bunch of divorce women taking classes to
better themselves and I was one of them
and I started taking Italian with no
plan and I fell so in love with it and I
said I want to master this to master and
I'm really going to have to go to Italy
and that was the beginning of me
creating the idea of going and spending
that year traveling starting in Italy
and then going to India to meditate and
then to Indonesia it would have never
come up
it would have never come up so so I
can't overstate what you can get out of
out of doing the artists way and I do it
I tend to do it between projects
actually I'm glad you brought it up
because I haven't done it in a while and
I'm just looking over at my bookshelf
and I see that the the book is sitting
right there and and I may take this as
an invitation to - it's a good thing to
do during quarantine dedicate myself to
it again and find out and the other
reason that it's important I think to do
it again and again is you don't know
what you're gonna find
um you know what like you change the
world changes and you change and I have
a feeling that if I did the artists way
again it's not going to be I want to
learn Italian on every page I don't know
what I'm going to find but but I'm
curious enough to find out and yeah why
don't I why don't I do that Tim thank
you thank you for fighting
I literally have I'm touching it with my
hand because it's it's on the table
where I'm working the artists way
morning pages journal which is a
companion volume to there is and I've
been using it I've got dusted it off and
said you know I think the monkey mind
has had free rein for long enough let me
wait wrap some of this in the amber see
what's going on we're on it's a full
body yes this is the other thing I'm I'm
really into lately is getting a full
body yes you know somebody mentioned
something in your whole body's like oh
yeah that's on which is actually going
back to it's actually why I started
doing psychedelics cuz I heard somebody
talking about it and I got a full body
yes for it um and I did it until I got a
full body now
but anyway so cool yeah the artists way
very important yeah I've been really
impressed with the power morning pages I
was introduced to morning pages by a
Brian compliment I will admit something
rather embarrassing that is
I've never taken or created an artist
state and I would love to hear if you
have taken yourself on artists dates
what maybe one or two of them have
looked like I okay I'll tell you one of
them was you know the High Line in New
York I do okay so before it was created
there was an article about it in The New
Yorker saying that there's this weird
strange thing running up the west side
of New York City so for those of you who
don't know at the High Line is this
amazing elevated pathway just one block
above New York that runs from down in
the Meatpacking District up until
Midtown it's expanding now but it's what
was remaining of what used to be an
industrial railroad track that was an
elevated railroad track that ran through
the city and it ran right through the
middle of certain buildings in the
Meatpacking District because they would
bring actually livestock and on those
trains and they would butcher them there
in the city so that the meat would be
fresh and then they would move the meat
out and
anyway the it had long been derelict and
falling apart and it was one of those
things that was too expensive for the
city to tear down and so it just was
allowed to kind of rot there and some
very forward-thinking citizens including
Gloria Vanderbilt and some other people
got together and decided to restore it
and to bring it to life as a pedestrian
walkway so it's this beautiful beautiful
beautiful gift to the city of New York
but the first time I read about it in
New York in The New Yorker years ago I
was living on 39th Street and 10th
Avenue at the time and it was describing
where this thing was and I realized it
was right around the corner from me and
and it had not yet been open to the
public at all I mean the project hadn't
even begun but I made it a point to try
to find it and it wasn't easy to find
because it's buried and like you know it
is the path of it disappears at times
and it goes under highway senator coast
so I spent an entire day tracking as
best I could
what was the beginnings of the High Line
and and even climbing even finding a few
spots to climb up and see if I could
look at it and get above it trying to
get into buildings so it became like a
sort of Tom Sawyer adventure that I took
myself on for a day so that was my
favorite artists date and and nothing
comes of it you know this is the really
great thing about these artist States
it's not that wasn't toward anything you
know that wasn't because I was working
on a book about New York City you just
do something that you think is
interesting and curious and you see
where it takes you and that's it and you
just make a habit of continuing to do
that and it's about kind of opening up
your life to to following your curiosity
even if it even if there's no
cost-benefit you know even if it doesn't
turn into some great big project or a
new business or anything you just you
just do it because it's fun and because
as I said before you're not just here to
pay bills and die yeah I will you know
I'll have to figure out how to make a
work in quarantine but I do need to need
to get on that artist State I think that
would be very good for my mental health
and just my spiritual health on top of
that
let's let's talk about city of girls for
a minute if this is your latest novel
and I think many people know you for
your nonfiction without knowing how much
experience you have and how good you are
at fiction I think that's worth just
saying since of course I you know Eat
Pray Love the 800-pound gorilla 15
million-plus copies I mean it's just
such a beast which I which I watched III
must say with admiration this juggernaut
because my first book came out in April
2007 and you were still dominating and
continued to dominate the lists forever
and so I remember watching that
phenomenon unfold in a real time which
was really fun
so congratulations fun for me too yeah I
bet the game like wow this is happening
yeah I didn't do it but it's happening
Wow yes anyway how closely this is just
a curiosity that came up earlier how
closely did the book proposal for Eat
Pray Love match the ultimate book and
was were there other titles you
considered the title was the last thing
I had and the title and now it's so
funny because it turned into such an
iconic it steals both surprising and
inevitable alright that title really
does seem it's all about the title right
but but that was the hardest title I
ever had to come up with I I had to
enlist every friend that I knew I had so
many other titles for it all of them bad
I kept trying to work with puns based on
the fact that all three of the countries
that I was going to begin with the
letter I and I was going on a spiritual
experience of the self so I thought
there's something in there it was so
labored so all of these titles have to
dumb it like the three eyes or the eyes
I like in search of I like every
everyday couldn't get off that you know
and finally it was it was a friend of
mine who came up with it's like oh that
works I'm just completely different but
as for the proposal so again you know
this this only works because this was my
fourth book this would not work for a
first-time book proposal or maybe even a
second one but
it was my fourth book and it was an
editor who I had worked with who knew me
and trusted me so I was able I guess to
get away with this but essentially I
just sat down and wrote him an email a
personal email and said I have this idea
of something that I want to do and I I
mean it just poured out of me as I think
it was like if you were to type printed
it was probably a page maybe a page and
a half and I said I'm I want to quit
everything and I want to go on this
journey and I want to look I want to go
to these three countries and I want to
look for pleasure I want to discover the
art of pleasure in Italy the the art of
meditation in India and I want to find
the balance between pleasure and
spirituality in Bali because they seem
to be a culture that's really good at
both of those things and and I want to
go for a year and I want to quit my
great job at GQ I want to get rid of my
create apartment I want to stop writing
novels I want to go do this I'd never
written anything so personal in my life
I'd up until that point been a fiction
writer and a biographer and and that was
it so it was I delivered what I said I
was going to deliver I didn't say what I
was going to find I just said what I was
gonna look for and and and and they were
generous enough to trust me to let me do
it to give me enough of an advance that
I could pay for the trip which was such
a miracle such a miracle I still think I
still remember that check coming in and
being like this is because I was
recently divorced I was like this is the
first money I've ever made that's that's
mine just mine the first money I've ever
made in my profession as a writer that
is just mine and I get to do with it
this adventure it was it just felt so
incredibly miraculous and it still does
what an incredible moment and what an
incredible feeling that must have been
you mentioned the art of pleasure city
of girls as you as you mentioned set in
New York City theatre world of the 1940s
there's there's one theme that I'd love
to hear you explore or expand
a little bit that is seemingly deeply
embedded in this and that is what it
means to lead a free and open sexual
life as a woman without suffering
terrible consequences can you just be to
that in any way that makes sense to you
yeah I I mean I wanted so much to to to
tell that story and to write that story
I as a female reader I've gotten so
tired over the years of the the trope
the cliche of the story of the ruined
woman and you know classically the story
of the ruined woman is woman from a nice
family respectable good prospects ahead
of her makes a terrible decision based
on passion and ends up dead it's like
one false move and you are dead and that
is the message that those stories convey
I mean that's Anna Karenina and it's
Madame Bovary
and it's Hedda Gabler and it's Daisy
Miller and you know all of those novels
written by men they should say and I
love them as works of literature as a
student of literature they're some of
the best books that have ever been
written but it's depressing as a woman
because you know it really it really
does they're meant to be warnings
they're meant to tell women to stay in
their Lane and and then there's this
other side and I'm gonna see if I can
get this over the net there's another
story that's told of women often by
women which is still the story of the
ruined woman that something bad happened
to a woman and her life was destroyed
because of it and in both cases what
what it you know what it's saying is
that women cannot survive life that
women cannot survive the dangers of of
being female they cannot survive their
own desire they cannot survive their own
risks they cannot survive men and that
just doesn't feel true to me based on
the empirical evidence of how many women
there are surviving you know like I like
to say if women could not survive the
terrible decision-making that we have
sometimes around sex and love I'm
talking about women our own terrible
decision-making around sex and love
there wouldn't be a woman left surviving
in this world like all of us have just
made such bad choices about ourselves
and about our bodies and yet we're here
and yet here we sit eating a sandwich
you know we're here and we're fine
and-and-and and bruised maybe but not
destroyed not destroyed I have
tremendous faith in female resilience
and I have every reason to have faith in
female resilience because the entire
history of womanhood is the history of
resilience and and that's a story that I
really wanted to tell about somebody who
and I really wanted to tell a story
about a woman who is very sexual and is
very sexual from a young age and then is
very sexual for the entirety of her life
who's very promiscuous and and has
consequences from that of all manner and
still remains somebody whose sexuality
is open and curious and who wants to
engage with the world at that level and
I feel like that's a very hard book to
find I don't think we've seen a lot of
that and and I didn't want to tell a
story about a woman who is sexual in her
youth and then puts it away to be get
married and become respectable I want to
tell story about a woman whose sexual
for the integrity of her life and that
is my character Vivian Morris and
there's a line in the book where she
says at some point in a woman's life she
just gets tired of being ashamed of
herself all the time and then she can
become who she truly is and I think
that's the that's the essence of the
book there's another line in there where
she says um you don't have to be a good
girl to be a good person that's the trap
that I think so many women fall into is
is trying so hard to be good that they
are not able to be who they actually are
are there any aspects portions of any
book you've written that you wished
readers would pay more attention to
something that in read
respect is important to you or you think
important to the reader that maybe
didn't get enough space or that people
just didn't take enough notice of is
there anything we're like man the thing
that people missed or didn't pay enough
attention to was this is there anything
that comes to mind in any of your
writing if there is it's my fault
because it's my job to be clear and and
and I and I take that responsibility and
I also have a great sense of the
autonomy of the reader to take away
whatever they they need and that they
want to take from it one thing that I do
think is funny and I wrote about this in
big magic is the this is the absolutely
bizarre but very human phenomenon of
people putting things into my books that
aren't there which i think is absolutely
amazing you know like I spoke about this
in big magic about a woman coming up to
me and saying you know because you spoke
so openly about domestic violence and
and and the the physical abuse that you
suffered at the hands of your first
husband I was able to leave my dentist
my domestic violence situation and I was
the last person in the world at that
moment who's going to say to her that is
not as important it's also not anything
that I've ever experienced and I don't
know why you put that in there but I'm
delighted that you left your abusive
marriage situation and I'd like I she
needed sometimes I think and I've had
this experience as a reader where I go
back to read a book that I loved and I
find that there's it's actually not the
book I remember reading which i think is
very strange and bizarre like the elves
came in the middle of the night and took
that part out of the book you know I
think it's almost like the way your your
your mind fills in the blind spots of
your vision with what it thinks is there
I think sometimes we as readers put in
things in books that don't exist but I
will say that with city of girls one
thing that I would I would ask you to
pay attention to as you read it is that
it's been it's been marketed and this is
fine with me because it is a book about
female sexuality it's been marketed as a
book about a woman who's who's very
promiscuous was very free with her
sexuality and and that's a very
important part of the book but by the
end of the book what I would love for
you to see is that it's a book about
female friendship and it's a book about
the families that we create versus the
families that we that we come from
and Viviane walks away from culture and
family she essentially walks away from
trauma and culture in order to become
her own woman and in that she finds her
own tribe and it's this group of women
who she is with for her entire life and
that is 1000% based on my I've been on
on my reality the female friendships
that I have that are decades long are
the foundational relationships of my
life I think that I was taught that the
most important relationship of your life
is going to be the person that you marry
and I I believed it once I believed it
twice and now at the grizzled old age of
50 and being very happy and myself as
Who I am now I can say that what I was
taught you were supposed to get from one
man I've actually discovered from a
multitude of extraordinary women and and
I feel a lot healthier as a human being
not looking for it from one person
anymore but receiving it from a
community and and from a community of
female friends and that's what Vivian
ends up with - the the the the key
relationships in her life are with her
aunt and with her best friend who is
also her business partner with the the
showgirls who she meets in New York City
who formulate her as a young woman into
a sensual being those are the
relationships that make her into who she
is and that support her through the
entirety of her life
here here I I have so enjoyed this
conversation we're running up on time
you're a gifted writer you're gifted
speaker this has been just the best way
I can imagine to spend coming up on two
hours as there is there anything you
would like to mention or talk about
before we wrap up and I'll certainly let
people know before we close up where
they can find you online and we'll put
everything in the show notes as well but
is there anything that you would like to
share or talk about before we close up I
thank you Tim I've had such a wonderful
time as well and anytime I get a chance
to talk to people on the subject of
mercy I just want to put in a word for
it
because I believe that we live in a
merciless culture and I believe that we
were merciless to ourselves
and I believe that we are very often
merciless to each other but most
merciless to ourselves because we've
been taught to be and and mercy is the
guiding word of my life right now and I
don't think that I'm going to be okay
mentally or spiritually without it and
it's such a lovely word it's such a
gentle word it's I love that it's the
word that you know if you're wrestling
with your brother it's the word that you
traditionally uses the word of surrender
right like okay enough like you know
mercy is something that I have only
found for myself in in moments of
surrender in giving up my illusions of
power giving up my illusions that I
control the world giving up my illusions
that I control anybody else giving up my
illusions that I'm meant to live some
sort of a perfect life
and accepting everything as it is and
feeling mercy toward myself for how
difficult it is to be human being you
know within that realm most people who I
know I wouldn't really have anybody
around me who wasn't like this so I can
I can say that most people that I know
would say that it's a goal of theirs to
practice universal human compassion that
that's something that means something to
them that they want to be a
compassionate person to the entire world
that they want to be a humanitarian that
they want to think of others that they
want to take care of that they want to
be kind they want to be forgiving they
want to be self selfless and most of all
that they want to be compassionate
universally and I just always want to
remind everybody especially if you're
out there and you're one of those people
who is practicing universal human
compassion as best you can while at the
same time assassinating yourself and
having voices in your head that are so
vicious to yourself and holding yourself
to such an impossibly high standard I
just want to remind everybody that
universal human compassion that does not
include the self is not Universal and
universal human compassion starts at
home by extending
an olive branch of mercy between you and
yourself and beginning and I would say
to love yourself but I know that that
can seem very out of reach to people so
I would say beginning to be friendly
towards yourself to treat yourself with
a certain level of stewardship and
friendship that says this is how I talk
to myself sometimes I say I don't know
why they gave me you I don't know why
they gave me you to take care of you
know but they did they dropped me into
your body they dropped me into this mind
they dropped me into this family they
dropped me into this culture they
dropped me into this moment of history
they gave me these talents they gave me
these mental illnesses they gave me
these gifts they gave me these
addictions I don't know why they gave me
you but I accept I accept that and I
accept the sacred responsibility of
taking care of you and I will take
really good care of you and I haven't
always but I will now and and that's the
beginning of reaching out a friendly
hand of mercy from yourself to yourself
and without which I don't think you can
actually practice universal human
compassion because the hardest person in
the entire world to like to endure to
forgive to show mercy for is of course
yourself and and once you've done that
like the rest of it's a breeze I'm never
gonna meet anybody who's as difficult to
handle as I am you know um you're never
gonna meet anybody you're never gonna
meet anybody Tim who causes you more
trouble than you cause II that's just a
rule like you know and and none of us
are ever going to meet anybody whose
shame is harder to forgive than our own
but but you know once I've learned how
to just be very gentle and gracious
toward myself and merciful again just
with that word I find that I can sit
with people now who are in all kinds of
bad behavior and it's less agitating for
me because I'm like oh hello me I love
George Saunders says when he sees people
the writer George Saunders who is a
practicing Buddhist as well
but he says whenever he sees somebody
acting out he always he has a name for
them a special name for them and that
name is me on a different day and it's
so kind and you know and until you can
really be kind toward yourself how could
you be kind toward you on a different
day which is everybody else so um so
just mercy is the word and it's the
thing that the world needs it's the
thing that you need towards yourself
it's the thing that the people that you
work with and live with need from you
and but mostly that you need from you to
you Liz you are doing such good work in
the world and you're sharing many
important messages please keep it up and
people can find you of course at
Elizabeth Gilbert comm they can find you
on social on Twitter and Facebook at
Gilbert Liz on Instagram at Elizabeth
underscore Gilbert underscore writer and
I will underscore Gilbert underscore
writer x4 14 underscore and I'll link to
you all of these so people can just
click on something in the show notes as
always it Tim dot blog for slash podcast
including everything we've spoken about
no not the least of which is your latest
novel city of girls which was named an
instant New York Times bestseller and is
a very fun book very exciting book very
thoughtful book rollicking sexy tale of
the New York City theater world during
the 1940s and I also owe a thank you to
Cheryl Strayed for making the connection
and setting in some ways the ball in
motion so that we can have this
conversation so thank you Cheryl and Liz
once again it's been such such a
pleasure and so much fun to spend time
with you and I appreciate you carving at
the time my very great pleasure thank
you so much Tim and thanks to everybody
for listening and until next time mercy
and compassion and if you mean it to be
universal that needs to
food you thanks for tuning in hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday if that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode of the Tim Ferriss shows brought
to you by athletic greens I get us all
the time if I could only take one
supplement what would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
they use it in a lot of different ways I
travel with it to avoid getting sick or
to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time and extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens comm forward
slash Tim again that's athletic greens
comm forward slash Tim for your free
travel pack with any purchase
this episode is brought to you by thrive
market thrive market saves me a ton of
money and it's perfect for these crazy
times thrive market is a
membership-based site on a mission to
make healthy living easy and affordable
for everyone
you can regularly save 25 to 50% off of
normal detail prices with member-only
prices for anything you can imagine
really whether it's keto paleo
gluten-free vegan whatever you can sort
by that you can find all types of food
you can find supplements you can find
non-toxic home products clean wine dog
food just about anything and let me give
you a personal example of just how much
you can save
so my last order I ordered primal
Kitchen mayonnaise which is made with
avocado oil it's delicious Justin's
almond butter and the first was 25% off
the Justin's almond butter was 30% off
raus homemade marinara sauce which is
awesome 26% off all said and done at the
end of my shopping I saved $39 on my
order so members and I'm a member can
earn wholesale prices every day and save
an average of $30 on each order I'll
come back to that and through thrive
gives their one-on-one membership
matching program every paid to thrive
market membership is matched with a free
one for a low-income family in need and
you can try thrive market a few
different ways they have the monthly
membership which is 995 per month they
have the 12-month membership for five
dollars a month which is billed at fifty
nine ninety five and right now this is
exclusive you guys you can get up to a
$20.00 shopping credit when you join
today now remember that I save 39
dollars on my order so basically with
one or two orders I pay for the annual
membership which is pretty sweet so go
to thrive market comm forward slash Tim
to give thrive market a try you can like
I said choose between the membership
models you'd like to test out if it
doesn't work for you you can cancel for
any reason within thirty days for a full
refund and on top of that
you will make back your membership in
savings as I have or they give you
credits to make up for the difference so
it's really win win-win all around
and I would suggest to check it out go
to thrive market calm phone / Tim you
can receive up to $20.00 in shopping
credit that's thrive market calm / / Tim
for up to $20.00 in shopping credit plus
all of the other great stuff than I
mentioned one more time checking out
thrive market comm forward / Tim
[Applause]
you